I remember in elementary school  putting celery in a glass of food  coloring and we were supposed to get  excited about the celery leaves turning  colors I could care less at that moment  however now I teach my students about  all those tissues and how the leaves  turn green through the transport of the  water through the xylem and I'm not sure  why I hated it so much back then but now  I just think it's the best thing ever  nerd nerd nerd all I totally am that was  fine  the turning point in sixth grade we  cracked an egg put it in a petri dish  and I did not realize there were so many  parts to an egg and I was fascinated by  that and so it's very important to give  students those opportunities to have  that active learning moment you never  know when one of those opportunities  might change the course of your academic  career  [Music]